Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 10th,
2018 how's it going?
How I yeah.
Oh,
why?
Yeah.
Um,
I am back from a whirlwind tour.
I the fucking crazy weekend.
I'm actually sitting here a podcasting in front of the TV,
which I know a lot of you don't like.
Simply the fucking Steelers in browns had a tie.
Wow.
Jesus Christ one that,
this exact reason why you don't like it.
This is the exact fucking reason cause I get distracted.
I haven't seen a fucking tie since.
Like they've had overtime.
I don't know.
I don't recall one.
Okay.
Um,
zero zero and one of the Pittsburgh Steelers and the Cleveland browns.
How about that?
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I'm sitting here.
I've got the Red Sox game on in the background.
The Houston Astros are trying to become the second team this season to sweep the
red sox.
Well,
Boston is trying to go two for two today against the city of Houston.
All right,
now we are already done.
Kicked the shit out.
You fucking football team.
Now we're trying with your baseball team.
I'll be honest with you.
Uh,
I thought the Patriots looked good for the first two and a half quarters.
Um,
special teams is letting up more yards than I would like.
Then you would like bill you as a what a football coach.
You as a comedian,
a shit joke.
Talon fucking jackass who decided to fucking record a game and fast forward
through the commercials.
Yeah.
Bill,
what did you see on your game film?
Um,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You know,
there's always room for criticism.
Who am I to sit here and act like I'm above it?
Um,
yeah,
I thought I was very impressed with our pass rush.
I was very impressed with our ability to,
uh,
contain,
what's his name?
Watson there.
I thought he was going to be a nightmare.
I also thought he might've been a little gun shy about running because he is
coming back from a knee injury.
So I thought when he,
he ran when he had to,
but I was impressed with him staying in the pocket.
Um,
I liked,
uh,
the new,
left guard we got there.
I left tackle,
I should say taking old for Nate soldier,
soldier,
I'll be you say his name.
He's the only there for fucking 20 years now he's playing with the giants.
Um,
Brown,
whoever that guy was just keeping all those beasts up front for of the Texas
where they get clowny.
They got JJ watts and then they got some other guy like maniac or something like
that.
Like his name is literally like,
it's like psycho or maniac or something like that.
I'm not a nickname.
Okay.
The name he was born with as a baby.
Oh,
look at that little cute baby.
What's its name?
Clarence Maniac.
You want to have a play date?
Uh,
no I don't.
Why am I fucking headphones?
Fucking God damn these fucking cheap ass fucking things.
I swear to God,
I just can't win.
Okay.
CanNot fucking win.
What is going on now?
This is all brand new shit.
I got all brand new shit.
Hear people.
Speaking of which,
if you want to fucking,
if you want to,
a couple of things.
I'm selling.
I just bought a new mixer.
Uh,
my old one works fine,
but I'm getting back to doing these uninformed with Joe to Rosa,
which is going to be up on my patrion page coming up here in November.
We're going to tape some episodes,
get a little in the can and that type of shit and some other stuff.
So I had to get a mixture where I could actually have enough microphones for
more than two people.
So I have a mixer with the chords and all of that shit.
Uh,
if you want to start your own podcast,
do you want to open up your little podcast shop across the street and compete
with me?
Uh,
let me know.
I'll figure it out.
Cause I already started Dean del Rey cell and some shit.
I got a drum kit that I'm selling.
All right.
I'll get all the information.
I'll have it posted on my fucking Twitter site.
Um,
I'm selling this,
uh,
one of those sonar,
like travel kits.
You know,
it's kind of like the,
uh,
Questlove one.
The,
the,
what is it?
Uh,
whatever that one that he does with the little fucking 18 inch bass drum.
It's the same thing,
but to sona.
Um,
and fucking beautiful.
I just don't have the room for it anymore.
I got a,
I made a little drum room in my,
uh,
garage so I don't have to have a studio space for my drum set.
And I brought the big boy kit home and I got that little one,
which fucking sounds great by the way.
And I also have the,
uh,
the,
the fucking pads there where it's silent,
you know what I mean?
Where it doesn't,
it doesn't,
uh,
you know,
the Mesh ones or the real ones.
I got it tuned up.
Nice.
My buddy tuned it up,
I should say,
um,
after I kind of fucked it up a little bit,
but um,
whatever,
that's what it's come down to people.
This is the new me.
Okay.
I'm getting,
yeah,
British shit.
And right now you know what?
My whole fucking day,
my headphones out working right now.
I have no fucking idea if you can,
I'm,
all I'm doing is just looking at the fucking mixture.
I know that you can hear me.
I haven't been able to,
I fucking came home.
I went to watch the fucking patriots game.
Uh,
my wife Angel,
that she is taped the game for me and then I'm sitting there watching it and it,
the thing just like,
it starts fucking up.
Then I've got to hit pause.
I gotta shut it off.
I've got to turn it back on.
It was doing like one of those fucking things and it started off.
It was doing it every couple of minutes then once a minute.
Oh fuck you.
You can't fall ball.
Fall Ball.
Is that fair or foul
father.
Alright,
sorry.
Um,
it's two to one red socks by the way.
It has
throws her up.
You just hit one down by the Pesky Pole.
It went foul.
MMM.
Anyways,
so then it started doing it like every 30 seconds and it was like every eight
fucking seconds and I was loving watching the game.
Tony Roma,
I'm calling it right now,
Tony Romo.
If he fucking keeps doing this shit,
he's going to be a hall of fame broadcaster.
I have never learned more shit
about football,
I don't think.
Maybe since I'm going back maybe to like John Madden.
Okay.
The way that guys breaking down all of this stuff and has always been all these
coaches and all this shit tried to do it somehow.
The Way Tony Romo does it,
it's like you get it.
He does it in real time.
MMM.
It's fucking amazing.
So I was enjoying that.
So you know how the world works out?
What are you enjoying something?
Well,
let's fuck up the recording of it.
So that's what ended up happening.
And um,
you know what it's funny about my fucking headphones is if I sit up and I'm
uncomfortable,
they work perfect.
But if I lean back and I'm comfortable,
I swear to God,
dude,
I don't,
I don't know what the fuck I think I did.
I kill Tesla and another fucking life.
Is that what I did?
And this is my fucking punishment.
This is literally all brand new shit.
I swear to God.
I don't know what the fuck I did.
I kick Edison and the balls during a previous level.
He's a fucking thief anyways.
Right?
I swear to God,
unbelievable.
And this is the shit,
right?
My wife never flips out about shit.
Like does she know why?
Cause it never happens to her cause she buys new shit and it works.
My wife will like lose her cell phone and grand central station and then I'll
call it and they'll just be some guy.
Yeah.
Yes I have it.
No,
no.
I'll bring it to you.
Right?
I lose my cell phone.
That's fucking it.
Over cold case file.
No leads,
no nothing.
That fucker is gone.
All right,
so it's better over here.
Little better over here.
A little better.
Now this fucking thing is hanging off here.
This whole fucking podcast.
It's just gonna be me bitching about this fucking wire that I just bought.
Now it's off.
Now it's on.
Oh,
I see.
What happens when there's a little bit of weight and it's hanging down.
All can't handle that.
Can you can't fucking handle a little bit of fucking weight.
Is that what it is?
I just figured what it out.
What it is.
Oh,
we got a quitter here.
Everybody.
We got a little fucking snowflake.
Let's just move the whole fucking table for you buddy.
Yep.
Everybody gets a fucking ribbon.
Oh,
my mixer just fell off the fucking table.
This whole,
this is just going off the rails here.
Why do I try to make my life easier?
It,
it doesn't work up.
So I uh,
can
I lean back,
can get in the old man,
put his fucking back up against the couch.
Hello,
test.
Oh,
there we go.
There we go.
All right,
so I'm back.
Yeah.
Well you just demo.
What'd you just saw there?
It was why my wife is sick of living with me and,
oh,
everything's a fucking conspiracy theory with me.
I really wish when those sort of challenging moments and in the first world
country as a blue eyed white male,
that was actually a challenging moment for me as people are,
are like literally fleeing war torn fucking countries.
Haven't,
God knows what done to them.
Right?
If there is a god and he's looking down right now and he hears all this
screaming and yelling and shit about stuff that's going on
and he finds out what's this?
What's this poor soul screaming about right after he looks at the horrors of war
and he's going to just see some bald 50 year old fucking moron doing a podcast
by himself yelling about a microphone cord.
He's just going to look down and it is a heat,
by the way.
All right.
Fuck all this feminist shit where now they're turning everything around,
you know?
Okay,
fuck this.
You know,
there's gotta be something that has to still be a guy,
right?
Why Not God,
Oh,
why do I love being an asshole?
I just,
I enjoy it.
I'm sorry.
I do.
All right.
He's going to be looking down.
It'd be like,
Oh,
who is that?
I made that.
All right.
Do me a favor when,
when he passes yet give them the,
uh,
tones to take the down escalator.
MMM.
I don't know where I'm going to go when I die.
You know,
you can even think about that shit.
I watched that Mr. Rogers,
uh,
won't you be my neighbor?
Did you fucking see that
you guys watched that thing?
Whatever you call it,
their documentary.
I have never felt like such a piece of shit in my life.
F after watching that.
He's definitely fucking weird though man.
He is so fucking weird.
You know,
it says the guy by himself losing his shit,
talking into a microphone.
I had the nerve to say this guy's weird,
but um,
I I yeah,
take it easy.
End of the getting gunned down.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
I a,
I watched that documentary and uh,
Fred Rogers.
Mmm Mike.
I said if this,
if,
if there is a god and Christians are right
and got his son without having sex with a virgin.
MMM Jesus.
I mean,
just
how do you even say it out loud and still believe it,
man.
It's just clearly written by guys who don't want sloppy seconds,
you know?
So then they got to have to have like that.
Like she's a virgin.
No one ever banged her before so she doesn't know what good sex is.
She doesn't know what a big Dick is.
Now I could feel comfortable
to mount this person.
I mean,
is that,
is that it?
Was that the underlying theme of all of that?
Huh?
Oh,
hey,
look at that.
That's sort of a feminist look at it,
isn't it?
I Dunno what it is.
Feel about now.
I'm sorry.
My apologies to everybody.
South of a fucking Washington DC Mason Dixon lamb there.
Do you guys know the first,
you know the Gettysburg address?
Yeah.
I had no fucking idea where that was in the first fucking battle of the civil
war.
I thought it was like,
you know,
somewhere in the SCC.
Okay.
They weren't big 10 country.
They weren't fucking Pennsylvania.
I had no idea.
We never would get that far.
We always start with those fucking three ships.
The Nina,
the Pinta,
the Santa Maria,
they came.
Oh,
they,
somehow they came over after a,
okay.
Columbus,
right.
Columbus came over to like,
I dunno,
like Cuba.
Well,
The Bahamas,
Haiti,
he was down around there.
Right.
And then the Nina,
the Pinta,
the Santa Maria,
they all came over together.
Right.
Sort of the first carnival cruise.
It's kind of like that without,
you know,
a workout,
Roman and scurvy and shit like that.
Right.
Big Belt Buckles.
It must have no credible neck muscles back then.
Huh?
A big fucking hat with that belt on there.
Looking down at your soggy fucking boots,
bringing your head back up.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
they were all trap easy.
The coach used to come off slide right off their fucking nonexistent shoulders.
So anyways,
we would start with that shit and then we would maybe get to the war of 1812
never fucked with the civil war as far as where I went to school.
We never fucked with it.
It was just our country fighting each other.
Why,
why would that be of interest to anybody?
You know,
maybe that was just northern as being cool,
you know,
not talking shit after winning.
We don't need to teach them that we won.
Right.
But down south they were always talking about probably saying that we cheated,
you know,
like people hate the Patriots.
Say we underinflated are fucking cannon balls or whatever the fuck they going to
say,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
let me,
uh,
somebody just sent me a text at Aaron Rodgers get hurt.
Okay,
please tell me I fucking hate when that happens.
Yeah.
Roger is done.
He grabbed that knee so fast.
It's bad.
Oh No.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I fucking hate you.
And because it's just,
there's nothing worse than that.
You know what I mean?
And I gotta tell you something.
If you're a vikings fan or a bears fan and your psych that that happens,
you're a fucking asshole.
You know,
I never wrote it for Derek Jeter to get hurt or any of that shit.
You want to,
you want to play in when the,
when you want to beat him with that best.
Um,
wow.
Does that change the NFC?
My buddy who actually knows something about football was,
was picking them to go to the super bowl.
Wow.
You know what that reminds me?
I remember that year when the jets were favored,
it was like the first game of the season test to verde,
you know,
blew out his Achilles
and,
uh,
who cried?
It wasn't terrellowens.
It was,
uh,
the guy from USC.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Just give me the damn ball.
Okay.
When did wide the wide receiver position become the diva position?
He used to always be the quarterback.
He was the guy always walking around with the big and slated fucking ego.
And somewhere in the last like 15,
20 years,
like all the emotional meltdowns come from the guys who like catch the balls,
you know,
that was my quarterback.
Okay.
Um,
just give me the Damn Paul.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
um,
so I worked up in Thunder Valley,
[inaudible] Valley fucking California.
Um,
the,
the farthest north.
I have been in Sacramento.
All right.
I was a,
I landed in Sacramento was a 30 minute drive.
And this guy,
fortunately he took like the back roads,
which is really cool.
So we went by all these,
these farms and uh,
I actually for the first time saw an almond tree.
I thought nuts came from the ground,
you know,
because I always,
I was going to baseball.
Whenever we go to a baseball game,
they give you the ones that they feed to the elephants.
What was it like?
The fucking,
you know,
the Budweiser of peanuts.
Almonds is sort of like the blue moon.
You get a little more fucking crafty beer.
Kind of snobby.
Right?
But they're there.
Those,
those elephant was,
they always seem like they're dirty.
Take me out to the ball game.
I didn't know that nuts came on trees.
I'm probably making an ass of myself right now either.
They all do.
Well that's the one that does or whatever.
But I know there's a lot of you right now just racing to look up this
information so then he could tell me how dumb I am.
Or maybe you fucking know that.
You know,
you don't know how to grow one.
You don't know when to pick it.
You just know where it comes from.
Right.
Um,
Chanel was a numb.
The biggest asshole ever is,
is that what happened?
No.
Bill,
you're the biggest asshole ever because you just had a meltdown about a fucking
wire.
Fair enough.
Jesus Christ,
the Buccaneers and saints 48 to 40.
I got to tell you before it's all said and done.
I,
I drew Brees is going to throw for more fucking everything than anybody,
unless Tom Brady keeps playing.
Yeah.
Cause I don't think drew Brees is doing that.
Uh,
drew versus time.
Tom Brady versus time like that shit.
Like today.
They were actually,
they said he was the oldest quarterback to throw a touchdown in the first game
of the year.
Other than George Blanda.
Who's the Gordy fucking how of of football as far as how long he played and,
and Warren Moon.
Yeah.
Who I didn't,
I didn't know he played that late.
I know he's,
he spent most out at least half his career up in the CFL.
Maybe that's why he didn't seem like he was at old because by the time he came
in the league,
it was already like eight years in the CFL.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
why do I have the fucking TV on?
Why do I give a shit?
Should I hit pause?
Let me hit pause.
You know,
at the end of the day,
I have a job here to do and it's the God damn it.
It's to make you,
people laugh.
Well,
you know what?
It's a new TV and I don't know how to do it.
Is this do it?
Oh my God,
it did it.
I hit the pause button and it paused.
Fuck that.
I'm hitting play.
I still have that thing.
You remember the old days when you pause your flat screen and then it's just
burned in there?
Whatever the fuck you were looking at.
Um,
all right,
let me look the other way.
Okay.
So I,
I watched,
uh,
won't you be my neighbor?
And then I also watched,
uh,
Chappaquiddick
you got to check both.
Both those movies out were incredible and,
uh,
any on me stay on track here.
So we took the,
uh,
the back roads up to this casino,
what their thunder bay,
nothing to be sorry.
Thunder Valley.
And,
uh,
you know,
every once in a while I'll actually watch the news and whenever I watched the
news,
it always puts me into a panic and makes me feel like I should live in the
middle of nowhere next to a lake with a bunch of guns.
You know?
And I know there's a lot of people in the cities probably think that stuff.
Okay,
well here's the deal.
The only way to live in the middle of nowhere is if you grew up in the middle of
nowhere,
cause then you know how to live out there.
Right?
You came from a family that
okay,
taught you how to hunt and all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
I'm too fucking old for that.
I got to go the snake Pliska skin route and try to stay in,
in a fit of fucking city.
You know,
I think I'm going to join the people that live underground in the sewers cause
it's going to be so fucking hot.
You know the red heads,
all US redheads,
we're going to end up on the ground and we're going to be coming up like a bunch
of filthy Malakai's.
So you guys better sharpen your fucking swords or whatever the hell you're going
to have.
Once you run out of bullets,
that's going to be the thing.
When you run out of fucking bullets,
then it'll be swords.
It just clubs and it's good.
It's going to become fucking Braveheart,
you know?
But not if we were all like Fred Rogers.
He'd be just sitting there in the middle of it.
It's such a good feeling to know you're alive and when you crawl up Otto that
manhole,
I would appreciate it if you,
what the fuck just happened?
He got all of that one.
How did it go from to all the here?
Three run fucking homer.
I don't even know who did it.
I missed it.
Very nice.
That's right.
Houston.
How does it feel to be old Chitlin people do that shit.
Um,
the big story here is that the Houston Astros are going to take two out of
three,
which this is a series.
Now,
this is one of these ones that I pay attention to because we're going to run
into these.
Some bitches
come October,
so I want to see how we match up my,
granted Chris Sale's not in there.
I don't know if price pitched,
I don't even know what the fuck's going on.
So anyways,
we get up there to thunder valley and it is literally a fucking casino just
surrounded by farmland and the Gig.
It's this giant stage just like out in the parking lot.
And if nobody's covered right,
if there was any sort of rain,
I was joking like everybody would just fucking leave and I would be
contractually obligated to do an hour in front of a bunch of plastic wet folding
chairs.
But I gotta tell you he was one of my favorite gigs I've had in a long time was
amazing.
The Sky was beautiful.
The only thing that was weird was like when motorcycles would go buy a head to
like stop doing my act.
Like I was only getting like heckled by those things that was joking about how
those people up there,
they probably don't wear helmets.
You know what I mean?
Anytime you have a problem,
you just drive off until a bunch of snow peas,
those things are probably nice and soft,
slow you down.
Um,
and then after that I woke up the next morning at like something ridiculous.
I want to say it was a
4:00 AM four and then I had to get on a 6:00 AM flight,
something like that.
I can't even fucking remember.
Slide is salt lake city and from Salt Lake City go to Toronto for tiff.
The Toronto International Film Festival is All freckles is in a movie called the
front runner directed by a Jason Reitman starring a Hugh Jackman.
And I just,
uh,
I saw it for the first time anyways,
let me tell you the whole fucking story.
So I,
one of my favorite things I've seen in an airport
standing in line,
right,
trying to find something healthy,
but she,
you can't really do.
And uh,
this guy in front of me,
he orders two bagels and he goes,
can you put butter on it?
Can you put,
I just want to bagels with butter on it.
And he's like already on his tip toes,
like over the counter and he's tall enough to see over the counter.
So I was like,
what?
He's one of these fucking guys like when you prepare his food,
he has all these fucking instructions and he's on his tip toes watching you do
it and immediately I'm just like,
God bless the fucking woman or man romantically linked to this fucking lunatic,
right?
So he's on,
he's on his tip toes that Yankee flows.
He's on his fucking tip toes watching this lady.
She sticks it in the little fucking conveyor belt piece of shit,
toaster and it comes out.
She's putting it to,
he's got good.
Can you put cake with the butter on it ma'am?
Could you just put the punch?
She goes,
what?
can can,
can you put the butter on it?
She goes,
yeah,
she goes to butters over there and he goes,
no,
I was just hoping that you could put butter on it while it's still hot so to
like melts.
Can you do that?
Could you just put butter on it while it's still hot and then close it up?
Can you do that for me?
She just looks at him and goes,
no,
just handed on the bag.
Now I know.
I've always made fun of that.
I hate those fucking places where all of a sudden you've got to finish making
the sandwich like you work there for free.
But just the way she just told the guy no,
and he was already annoying me the way he was up on his fucking tip toes
like,
Gee,
what?
What the fuck?
You didn't order like a,
I'm trying to think of something fancy.
You all did a fucking Bagel.
She's going to toast the thing.
She's going to stick it in a bag.
You're going to pay for it.
Then you're going to go over to the condiments.
Try to find something that wasn't sneezed on.
You know how it's going down.
Okay.
So I laughed and she looked at me and gave me like half a smile.
She's like,
what do you want?
I'm just like,
I'll take one of those ham and cheese sandwiches.
You know?
You know what the only thing,
mmm.
Oh,
that was great.
Watching that guy gets shut down.
I don't know why.
It's like you,
you see a little spoiled fucking Brat kid crying,
you know,
cause he wants something.
Is there anything better watching a parent not cave and then the kid doesn't get
it.
I find I live
for that moment.
He,
when the kid cries and cries and cries and then the parents end up just giving
it to them.
Okay.
I was mixed.
We just want to like trip him.
Isn't that stupid?
I don't,
obviously,
I'm just saying,
you know something I do think about.
I'm not proud of it.
We all have our flaws occasionally.
Yes,
I see,
I see.
A kid gets stopped and after crying and uh,
makes you want to triple and it's stupid because the kid doesn't have the
emotional maturity to express himself.
Right.
What,
how Fred Rogers would have handled that if he didn't want them to have it.
Why are you crying?
Well,
you can't have all my God,
what a fucking moron.
This,
this fuck God blessed it.
There's a woman there,
she's wearing a Houston Astros fan.
She's wearing like one of those,
you know,
they'd make the number one finger out.
She's got a giant Orange Astros' hat.
Like to the point you're blocking people's view behind you.
Those are the things.
It's because of hats like that and people like that that where am at games.
That's one of the reasons why like things like flame throwers are not legal to
the general public because that's the kind of thing when you sit there for nine
fucking innings.
Alright.
And that's self centered,
can't,
won't take the fucking thing off.
That's one of the things,
if you had like a,
a,
a handheld,
well not seen,
you'd burn her up,
but you'd like the hat on fire and God knows what that's made out of and it
might,
you know,
touch somebody else's fucking hat and then they're on fire and you're like,
but no,
no,
no.
I just wanted to set her on fire.
I'm sorry sir,
my bed,
my bed.
Would you like me to drive you to the burn unit?
No.
Most of your ear is still attached.
MMM.
Anyway,
so then I flew up to Canada and I checked like 9 million times that I had my
passport because that's one of the things I always,
you know,
the first half of my career,
you could just go to Canada,
like you were going to your friend's house.
He didn't need a passport,
you know,
and then after nine,
11,
shit,
don't even say nine 11,
that horrific event
in,
uh,
ever since then you've got to have you fucking passport to go everywhere.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I checked like fucking nine out of times,
make sure I had my passport.
Um,
and I went through the customs and everything and I think I got there at like
four o'clock and then like the pickup was like at five 15.
So by the time I got through customs and all of that shit ordered room service
and everything,
like I had time to iron my stupid shirt and then I went over there and I did the
whole,
uh,
you know,
the whole red carpet got asks great questions.
Nobody tried to corner me.
You know,
there was a couple of,
how would you relate this movie to a,
what's it going on today in the current political climate?
You know,
it was fine.
There was no,
uh,
wait,
what do you think about this guy going back on stage?
I already knew what I was going to say.
Well,
what do you think about it?
That's all I ever do.
If you ask me one of those and your career questions,
I just throw it right back at you.
What do you think about it?
No,
I'm asking you.
Well,
I didn't ask the question.
You're the one who has the question.
You're the one thinking about it.
What do you think about it?
I want to hear it.
I want to you put a quote on it.
What do you think about it?
There they have fucking,
uh,
Jimmy Olsen.
So then we,
uh,
I went into the,
this beautiful theater and sat down and watched the movie and I gotta tell you,
man,
it's pretty fucking incredible.
Uh,
Jason Reitman killed it.
it's called the front runner and I would not be,
I don't want to Jinx Nda.
I'm not going to jinx nothing,
but I would not be surprised.
I'll go real.
I'm going to really
go low here.
That if it performs very well,
that's,
that's as much shit as I'm going to talk.
Um,
but it's a phenomenal,
phenomenal movie.
And the way the whole thing was cut together,
the way they told the story.
And uh,
it's really,
really fascinating.
It's about the,
uh,
the Gary Hart story,
which a for you youngsters out there.
He was a guy running for president in 1988 and yes,
he was the front runner.
Great Looking Guy.
Guys like them ladies loved them.
Full head of hair,
you know,
that's the kind of shit that gets you elected.
Right?
Play the saxophone on our city.
Oh,
Hall.
Two terms,
not one,
two terms.
Ah,
Shit.
Did they just hit a fucking home run guy that was a monster shot five to,
to the Astros?
No.
Quit numb.
You know why?
Cause they're champions.
Um,
oh man,
that's that fucking guy.
What is his name?
That's the guy.
Last year,
the world series.
It was incredible.
You know,
the dude that I was Al today,
right?
That guy,
that guy's worth every dime.
You pay him.
You know what else I like?
I like that guy in the infield for the Texas Rangers,
total winner.
The guy will punch that dude in the face.
Um,
credible ballplayer,
man,
that's going to be a shame watching the red sox or Yankees by him,
away from the Rangers.
Although back in the day,
the Rangers spent all money on a Rod,
right?
220 million bucks.
So they got money.
That's Texas,
man.
You sitting on all that fucking oil.
Why don't you take some of that money,
put it on your team.
Um,
anyway,
so I got there when,
thank God every,
like the,
uh,
I got there on time and I got to see movies.
Phenomenal.
Everybody in it is so fucking good.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I had my head down whenever here my boys put my head down.
But,
uh,
you know,
I watched,
I actually watched most of my seats and I wasn't cringing too badly.
So I think,
uh,
I think I did all right in it.
Uh,
but I want to thank everybody for,
uh,
everyone I worked with and given me the opportunity to be in it.
But I think it's going to be a great one.
So guys,
could you do me a favor?
I know you're all streaming shit.
I know you got your fucking virtual reality glasses with the laser disc players.
Whatever the fuck he kids are doing nowadays.
Could you just go old school?
Okay.
Just go to the movies when it comes up.
Just go see this thing.
All right.
Do it for me.
So one day I can afford to buy speaker wires that actually are microphone wires
that actually work.
Okay.
It's for a cost.
This is a startup.
I think it comes out November.
Um,
go see it.
You will not be disappointed there.
That's it.
All right,
plowing ahead.
I'll look at a rod,
a rods in the fucking box deck.
There's another guy,
another guy,
Tony Romo and Alex Rodriguez.
I say,
oh well they're the two best former athletes turned broadcasters in a long
goddamn time.
It's unreal how when a rod was a player and,
and the New York media would be asking them all those questions.
He,
he get like tongue tied.
You get them in the booth.
He's just the seas.
Effortless.
Fucking effortless.
All right.
Speaking of effortless,
not effortless,
I should say.
I got to do some reads here for the week and I forgot to turn the God damn light
on
some ways is such a good feeling.
So now you can read.
Ah,
Jesus.
So anyways,
and then this morning I had a 6:00 AM
6:00 AM flight.
What was awesome,
there was nobody like in Toronto,
I've gotten some of the worst traffic other than La and Chicago and some of
those other fucking places.
Toronto is just brutal traffic.
And I woke up this morning and there was nothing,
nobody out there on a Sunday morning.
And uh,
went right through customs,
thing of beauty.
And then I went to go buy some fucking Cuban cigars there and their prices were
out fucking rages,
dude.
I was looking at,
I was looking
at a box of them.
They want to like 500 to 60 bucks.
It's like,
dude,
I can get these things in.
I don't,
people in la got these things not paying all that money.
So in a bind like these,
these,
these little ones about like five,
I mean what the Hell you call it?
Oh Shit.
Now they're fucking hitting us.
Now they hit somebody else.
How many outs here?
So top of the six a game.
You guys already know the results of its five to two.
This has never been good other than the fact that one time when the guy ran the
ball back to win the game,
that was the only time this was a good move to have the fucking game on.
Um,
all right,
let me read some of the,
um,
okay.
All right.
Let me read some of the uh,
advertising here.
Oh my bookie,
everybody,
you know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people have been asking me for advice.
Ask me what team to bet on.
I don't know if he ever asked me that.
You guys did ask me back in the day who I liked,
who I thought I was going to suit both.
The truth is,
I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think you know,
you got to check out my bookie,
remember who you're betting on is just as important as who you're betting with.
That's why,
uh,
you need to go to my bookie.
Okay.
Trust them.
According to them,
they're your best bet.
This season they'd been in business fee.
They have great reviews online and their mobile site is easy to you.
I would,
I would love to read reviews of gambling sites.
Okay.
Um,
but what I've left myth fucked his sat.
I would only recommend a service to my listeners.
That's been good to me.
The,
the you guys,
my book,
you have to change this fucking copy.
Okay.
I don't gamble.
All right.
Well,
I mean I gamble with my friends.
I don't go to a site here.
Okay.
You've been good to me and that you're paying me money to read this shit.
But I mean,
I haven't done anything with you guys.
Okay.
Anyways,
that's why evidently I'm urging you to make your way to my bookie.
You,
when they pay,
that's how it works.
They have in game live betting the most rewarding player perks in the business
and you for you fantasy guys out there,
I like this shit here.
You can even bet the over under on how many fantasy points of player will score
each game.
Join now and my book,
He will match your deposit dollar for dollar.
I liked Baeten on stupid shit coin tosses.
You know what I mean?
That's like the appetizers to like your real bet.
Just to keep your fucking going anyway.
She use the Promo Code burpee you are are to activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie Myb o.
O,
k.
I.
E.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code [inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play,
you play,
you win,
you get paid or you lose and you don't get laid.
You know what I realized is that I bought this,
this fucking microphone,
wire headphones,
Shit,
all this stuff and it's so heavy that it was hanging off the table.
That's why everything actually works.
Once again,
I fucking flip out and there it was a simple solution and there was no reason to
have a meltdown.
I do it all the time.
Okay,
so now they got fucking two guys on base.
Nobody out.
We got to write in a lefty warming up in the bullpen.
This is why the Astros won it last year.
You cannot put these guys to bed.
Can't talk him in.
All right.
Policy genius.
September is national life insurance awareness month.
Most people aren't aware of that.
In fact,
most people aren't aware they need,
well,
most people,
I'm fucking away.
The light turned green,
too busy staring at the God damn phones.
In fact,
most people aren't aware they need life insurance at all.
That's why 40% of people don't have it.
Well,
I mean it's not that they're not aware of which a lot of it is guys and we don't
like dealing with their mortality.
Um,
but I've,
I did it.
I have my affairs in order and I cannot tell you as,
as a husband and a father knowing that when I Croak,
everybody that I love in my family is going to be okay.
It's great.
Then you can have like a happy funeral.
You know,
people show up and brand new,
uh,
black clothing
anyways,
but getting life insurance doesn't need to be difficult or expensive.
Right now prices are the lowest they've been in 20 years.
Okay.
Why is that?
Is it because people are living longer and policy genius has made it easier than
ever to get covered?
Policy Genius has helped over 4 million people shopped for insurance and placed
over $20 billion in coverage and they don't just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
renter's insurance,
and health insurance.
If you care about it,
they cover it.
So if you're looking for a good reason to buy life insurance,
here's three.
It's national life insurance awareness month.
That's not a good reason.
Okay?
Okay.
It could be national ghetto hooker month doesn't mean you should go do it.
Right?
So that one's out.
Prices are at a 20 year low.
That's a good one.
And policy genius makes it easy to get the right policy for you.
Wait,
they said there was three reasons.
National Life Insurance awareness month prices are at a 20 year low.
Oh and then is policy genius makes it easy to get the right policy for you.
There you go.
I got a policy,
genius.com get quotes and apply in minutes.
You can do the whole thing on your phone right now.
Policy genius for all you dummies like me,
p o l.
I.
C.
Y.
G.
E n.
I.
U.
S the easiest way to cook.
Way To compare and buy life insurance.
Genius is not an easy word to spell.
It's an easy one to fuck up.
Like restaurant.
That's an easy one.
Um,
anyways,
draft kings.
Okay.
Uh,
it's week two of the football season.
Is it?
Well I guess it goes,
it's,
yeah,
cause I'm supposed to be reading this tomorrow.
Uh,
but there's still Monday night anyways,
which means a second shot at victory.
Bragging rights and huge cast prices are up for grabs all season long at draft
kings.
The lady in one week,
fantasy sports this weekend,
draft kings has over $2 million in total prizes and you can play for free with
your first deposit to come Pete,
for your share,
uh,
with one week fantasy,
a draft kings,
you choose when to play.
Draft a new team every week with no season long commitment.
At draftkings you are the GM.
Just choose your players,
stay under the salary cap and see how you,
how your team stacks up against the competition no matter what your skill level.
That's so fascinating.
Now,
you know,
they got like the Deniro character handicap and each team,
every now the salary cap has to be different for every team,
right?
Do they do that?
That would be fucking incredible
if they did that and they,
they'd pick the Indian all,
they pick that perfect fucking number so he can't quite get all the guys you
want.
That's where the skill comes in anyways.
No matter what your skill level is,
is a contest waiting for you at draftkings.
So if you've been waiting up,
uh,
but thinking about trying one week fantasy football,
now is the time to play because nothing makes football Sunday more exciting than
when you put your whole fucking paycheck down on it.
Then when you bet responsibly that when you have a draft kings line up on the
line,
download the APP or go to draft kings.com now use promo code burpee you are are
to enter a contest for free this weekend,
uh,
with your first deposit and compete for your share of over $2 million in total
prices.
That's code bur bur are at only a draft kings Jesus the game inside the game.
Minimum $5 deposit required eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
Um,
okay.
Do you know what I really miss?
I miss football cards.
That's how I knew who everybody was in the league.
I fucking,
yeah,
miss those things.
And what happens was all those fucking baseball cards in the 1950s,
all the Mickey Mantle rookie cards and all that shit blew up.
And where with all that money.
So by the time I became an adult,
so many adults were collecting cards.
Kids didn't give a shit about it.
And then I'm,
I try collecting football cards again and they,
they would like deliberately make some of them rare.
You couldn't just go out and go buy a whole sec cause that's what people were
doing and then they weren't fucking worth anything.
Let me see.
Tops.
Okay,
let me see.
They still have these things.
Football car,
Duh.
Okay.
Uh,
2018,
2018.
What do you got here buddy?
Will my internet work?
You know what?
I don't even care if it does or it does or doesn't.
I'm not going to flip out about it.
How about that?
Just relax bill.
Just count to 10 slowly.
What?
You know what I,
I got a,
I got a master going for a walk the other day.
I got into with my wife,
right.
And,
and I,
I started to walk away but I didn't leave,
you know.
All right.
Shop tops,
football cards,
2018 football cards.
Release dates.
Yeah.
All right,
let's see what they got here.
It's such a good feeling.
I used to just sit there and like I wouldn't study in school and I would just
look at football cards and I would read,
I would look at the picture and I would just read them over and over and over
again.
It didn't realize it was like flashcards.
And by the end of it,
I knew everybody in the league.
I knew where they went to cook cause I would watch it every year.
I get the cards every year.
And there was all these guys that I already knew shit about and there was only
so many new rookies.
And uh,
I remember he used to blow my dad's mind.
I was like,
and he went to college.
It'd be,
can't stay
Louie couches.
See as a size 16,
quadruple east a clique.
You like Jesus Christ.
How do you know all of this stuff bill,
while dad,
cause I'm not studying
all that effort that I should have put in to my studies.
So I could've gone to a,
to a,
to a big time college,
you know,
and he joined a Frat,
walked around,
you know,
maybe join the glee club or whatever.
I've had an acapella group,
you know,
met some women,
get me two fucking years later.
I just missed out on it.
Um,
when the fuck is this thing gonna load.
All right.
You know,
I'm just,
I'm just going to start read some questions.
Maybe there's at some point I don't,
I know for the life of me,
I don't know how much money I have to pay these internet guys to get something
that works.
You know,
I was,
I started to talk about this where a buddy of mine had a,
you know,
he solved this Internet prom buddy.
They got these things called like mesh or something like that where it ties the
Internet signal from one party house to another.
And that just seems like you are in
the Tsa Line for fucking brain cancer.
Like it's bad enough.
We've got all these,
did this,
it can't be good.
I don't know what it is,
but there's something going on you.
We've all done it.
We've all talked on a cell phone long enough that like the society of fucking
one side he head starts feeling weird.
You know what I mean?
I used to a bit about that.
So then you talk with the cell phone,
the other side of your head sort of sear it like a fucking tuna steak.
It's just your brain.
All right.
Eastern European tour.
Hello Bill.
I am writing from Croatia.
I like to ask you if you are still coming to this part of the world.
My part of the world,
not yours.
Just kidding.
Yes I am.
We're just working it out because a,
the dates came in and I was going to be gone for too long.
I have a kid so I'm trying to break it up into two different tours.
Do a week to 10 days and then come back a few months later and do another week
to 10 days.
10 10 days,
10 days,
10 days.
So that's what I'm trying to do.
Okay.
I promise you it is going to happen.
All right.
Outdoor venues.
Uh,
why did one this weekend?
So I am ready.
I'm ready for this question dear Billy.
Operation Northwoods.
Look it up.
All right,
well my internet work.
Sure.
I would love to look it up.
It's still loading.
All right.
Um,
thanks for the killer show in the casino parking lot.
Oh,
thank you for showing up.
Anyways,
he said,
I've heard you mention a guy named La head before,
but I never knew shit about him.
Fucking hilarious guy.
Yeah.
J Law had Jay lie.
Come on man.
That guy a fucking kills it on the grill too.
Okay.
Follow him on Instagram.
You see that guy when that guy starts cooking,
it's fucking crazy.
It's like a cooking show.
Uh,
how come he's not on Netflix or seesaw?
I think it's Cecil or whatever the fuck you guys do.
Anyways.
Wondering if the parking lot is up there in the weirdest outdoor venues.
You've played at a,
all right.
Why is it j on Netflix?
Well or CSO went out of business.
What else is there?
Hulu,
Amazon and all that.
Well,
eventually it happens for everybody.
Everybody,
you know,
takes people different amount of time.
You know,
look,
I started in 1992 and it took me until either 2005 or 2006 to get on Letterman.
And I went through a couple of bookers a couple of days was just like yeah I
don't like you.
Right.
You got a weird,
we get a weird look as one that I got.
Well I don't think that was in the letter of people but um,
yeah,
you know it was hilarious.
I remember years later seeing this other generations of comedians and they were
like bitching about the book booking process and they will like seven years in.
It's just like,
well hey fucking buck up buddy.
It's going to take you another A.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's not how it works is that our works nowadays.
Cause now there's social media cause now you fucking complaint and then
everybody's afraid to get in trouble and nobody,
nobody just goes like,
hey you don't have,
fuck you.
Oh Shit.
Fuck
that's a run scored two run score
to run school.
All my God,
these fucking Houston Astros are relentless.
Look at them.
They're all up there.
Yeah.
Top of the dog.
This is impressive.
This is what we've been doing,
the teams all year and now they're coming in giving us the old right there,
Fred.
Fuck.
I already know what this saying with the sound dial.
That ball got up there in the zone.
I mean that thing you want that much lower.
This is like,
that's right in his wheelhouse and he jumped all over it.
His eyes,
they opened up like a kid on Christmas.
Uh,
fuck me.
Um,
anyways,
I love that you guys know that the result of this Houston chance.
So I was talking all that shit like we're gonna whip y'all fucking cities as
today.
MMM.
If there is a sports god,
just because that woman is wearing that giant stupid fucking hat in,
in a visitor's stadium,
you know?
I mean just how many times can you just ask to get your fucking ass kicked
before it happens?
MMM.
Anyways,
yeah.
So people like,
Then started whining about,
I dunno how long it takes or whatever,
and then I guess it shorten up.
It's so fucking stupid.
Show new teach hort.
Ooh.
It's particularly hard for me.
It's like,
what are you,
what are you seeing out there?
Like,
here's the deal.
It might be more difficult for you,
but nobody has it easy fucking sitting there acting like,
God damn fucking Spielberg sends me a fucking sandwich every day.
MMM.
Which would be nice if he's listening every once in a while.
Uh,
all right.
Outdoor venues.
Yes.
Um,
where's the weirdest venues that I've played,
outdoor venues that I played it.
I used to open up for Wynonna Judd way back in the day and we,
uh,
we did a lot of outdoor venues.
Um,
you know,
when you sell on that level of tickets,
she basically was selling so many tickets that they didn't have an indoor venue
big enough.
So the half,
you have to go outside at some point.
So I open it up up for her at the,
I believe it's the del Mar race track.
I thought I told this story.
Okay.
So I go down there and it's one of these deals where they're like,
hey,
you know,
work clean.
This is a country crowd.
These people,
uh,
they don't like Carsick,
which,
you know,
you have to respect.
It's not my crowd.
I'm opening for this person.
This is what they've created,
you know,
Volu young comics out there to then go up there and,
and,
and curse anyways is a,
that's not a Lenny Bruce moment that,
that you're,
you're acting like a jerk off.
Cause they,
they probably told you before they even got the Gig,
you got to work clean.
So if you're not going to work clean,
don't take the Gig,
but don't say you're going to work clean and then go up there and start talking
about your nuts.
Oh,
you're far more accurately these days.
You're fucking Twat.
Cause female comics are that fucking Dick Joe Comics of today.
Some of the fucking filth that I,
I mean some of the bits it's just like,
I remember this bit except there were Dick and balls and I was standing in a bar
trying to figure out how the fuck am I going to follow this shit.
MMM.
Anyways,
so,
uh,
I had to clean
it was during the day,
which actually didn't bug me because I was psyched because I was making money.
I always loved like those gigs,
like a lot of times the news and Shit sucked.
But what was awesome was when it was over,
you had your check and you already made money and you could maybe double up and
do another Gig or you were like done
at like a normal hours.
So,
um,
well that never happened.
You know,
you always went out and did more fucking time.
Are we gonna do sit at home and be alone with your thoughts?
Okay.
So I went down there
and why nodal was always like really nice to me.
Um,
and I went down to open up and I got to work clean.
It's outside,
I'm in the sun,
I'm a redhead.
I still had my hair back then,
so I didn't need a hat and a,
I'm up there and I'm doing my shit.
And all of a sudden this lady in the crowd who I'm going to go out on a limb and
say was a lesbian,
you know,
she had that haircut,
the whole fucking thing.
And I know you're not,
you're not supposed to do well at least you're not supposed to do that with
lesbians.
You know,
you could do that with other groups of people,
you know,
don't be a Brad,
don't be a Chad.
You can,
you can fucking do that.
But if you go the other way,
all of a sudden you're an asshole.
Uh,
but yeah,
I mean if I had to put my life savings on it and the same people that were
criticizing me,
if it was a life or death situation,
if you had to put money on it,
you would say this was a lesbian.
Right.
Why is it pertinent to the story?
Because I'm painting a picture.
All right,
and are you liberal cuts out there acting like you don't have a fucking idea in
your head when I say that,
that she was a lesbian,
you have no fucking idea what I'm saying.
What if I said it was a frat boy,
you got your boom,
you get out to get that picture in your head.
Right.
Um,
anyways,
so she sit there and I'm on stage.
It's she shit the whole,
like I maybe get three minutes into my act,
we'll fucking outside.
It's brewed
and she's just standing.
She starts going,
why?
No why?
No,
no.
And she's trying to get the rest of the crowd to do it with her,
which they're not thankfully,
but she's fucking relentless.
And I,
I don't know if I did a joke that she didn't like,
or maybe it was that I had at Dick.
I have no fucking idea who,
or maybe I was just an pasty or maybe she thought I was weird looking.
Well,
maybe she was just a cunt.
I have no idea.
But she's doing that and I'm sitting there
and I want to go off on her,
but I got to work clean.
So I actually just stopped and I gathered myself and I said,
Hey lady.
I was like,
what is the problem?
Why are you Channing Wine Wynonna?
Why?
No,
not she's going to come out here at eight 30 no matter what she's coming out at
eight 30.
Okay.
Do you think I thought all you guys came out here to see me.
Yeah,
I know why I'm here.
I'm dancing monkey boy,
but Blahblahblahblahblah and uh,
I got the crowd on my side and then I made fun of her haircut.
I had to,
I had to do it cause I had to make sure I got all the Trump supporters on my
side.
I was flailing and then I got him and I started having getting labs and that
lady was pissed and she was still Janet.
Why?
No,
no,
but now it's drowning her out with laughs and I was winning.
Yeah.
Oh,
redhead in the sun with this pasty freckled back up against the nonexistent wall
was turning it around
and then out of nowhere the crown went from laughing on it.
No,
they just went
wow.
All at the same time.
And I couldn't figure what the fuck happened.
I thought my fly came down.
I had no idea.
And I turned around and behind me was way off in the distance,
was a carnival.
And there's some ride where they just shoot you up in the fucking air,
like,
like superman.
So I'm standing there fucking finally getting the crowd and right as it's
starting to pay attention to me in the way in the background,
some guy got shot up in the fucking air on this ride,
and then I kind of made fun of that.
Oh,
not another hit.
Ah,
another head,
another run scores.
And we got ourselves a tie game,
five to five,
just like that.
Oh.
Coaches coming out to the mound.
Jesus Christ.
Wow.
And with deep into our fucking bullpen already.
This is not looking good guys.
MMM.
Anyways.
Uh,
so yeah,
that was a weird one.
I've done also,
I've done college gigs in a,
uh,
sort of that area,
you know,
the Walker's shame area between dorms.
I've done that.
And there was also like sort of a carnival thing set up.
There's always a fucking car.
It was always rides some sort of popcorn machine.
MMM.
I remember a long time ago,
this one was actually inside.
MMM.
It was me,
Patrice,
O'Neil,
Robert Kelly,
Dane Cook,
and Al Del Benny.
We all doing this gig
and it was something,
some sort of Jewish thing.
I don't remember what was a function hall and the crowd was was predominantly
Jewish.
I don't know.
It couldn't have been fucking,
they don't go to church.
Where do they go to temple?
I could couldn't have been related to that or they wouldn't have hired us.
I don't know what it was,
but all I know is we were up there
and
none of us were in the business long enough to recognize like we will go.
Why is this microphone so small?
Like you could hold it with just your two fingers.
I remember Al went up there first go and this is the smallest microphone I've
ever seen.
Then he put it in his mouth and started humming or whatever and people laughed
and I was like,
oh my God,
I got to hold that thing.
Now I've got to go up after him.
Right.
So we did the whole,
we did the whole fucking show.
I remember when Patrice get up there,
he was holding it with his big fucking fat fingers.
Just holding this little thing is three things.
Like he was holding a teacup and a,
it wasn't until years later when I did my first TV Gig that I realized it was a
lapel mic and none of us knew to just clip it on your shirt and then just walk
around like you're doing the one man show,
you know,
with both hands.
So we all,
we would like finish our act and there was a Mike stand and we would like drape
it over and then the next guy would come up or just pick it up with his index
finger and his thumb.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know.
I gotta be honest with you.
All of those hell gigs,
they all just kind of,
they kind of fade away after a while.
I can't,
I don't remember.
I just know I've had a bunch of shit thrown at me.
I think I just,
after a while you just,
you don't want to remember him.
MMM.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I,
I've,
I've done some,
I've definitely done some weird,
I know I've done,
I did one outside up Mondale fucking west side highway.
There was like boats and shit
and all these fucking flies and stuff.
Yeah.
These are all starting to come back home.
It was hottest shit too.
Yeah.
And I was up there and I had like a long sleeve button down cause I just worked
like a comedy club so they had like the air conditioning cranking and then I
went over and did that Gig and I was like sweating my ass off.
Yeah,
I've done it.
I've done a lot of those.
That's kind of par for the course that happens.
Um,
that was a fun one though.
I opened for Wynona outside in a,
in a,
in a parking lot,
parking lot,
race track,
the occasional theater.
I opened up for an a parking lot in Laughlin,
Nevada.
Jesus do.
Why are you bringing back all of these memories?
All right.
A smoothie,
dear bill,
years and years back you said Kevin James told you the benefits of having liquid
first in the morning to get your engine going.
Kevin James.
I don't know if you get the name right.
I've only met him like once a smoothie,
water,
et cetera.
Then a few years ago you basically said,
fuck that because you thought it was too much.
It might have read it was bad for you.
Now you're doing smoothies.
Do you think it'll stick this time?
No Pun intended.
Go blend yourself.
Uh,
well,
I didn't know how to make one healthy back then.
You know what I mean?
There's a lot of them.
It's just like,
you do all this stuff and there's a bunch of sugar in shit that you're putting
in there.
Um,
now that I've been using like,
um,
unsweetened almond milk,
almond milk,
I used to hate it.
Now I'm kind of used to it.
Uh,
I got a good one for you.
one cup of,
uh,
almond milk.
I literally a miming doing this,
putting this shit in.
Uh,
then it's like a teaspoon is cinnamon,
a frozen banana,
two tablespoons of almond,
peanut butter.
MMM.
A tablespoon of Maca powder.
Some ice,
a little bit of ice.
You blend that fucker together.
It's delicious.
Tastes like a God damn chocolate shake and you'd drink it and you have energy
for hours.
MMM.
I gotta be,
I gotta be honest with you.
If,
if I actually knew enough about nutrition and all I could do,
if all I could do is just that
mmm.
And just do a liquid diet,
I would love to do that.
I would absolutely love to do that.
MMM.
There's another one I have that's like Kale.
It says apple juice.
That's the only thing I don't like.
It's apple juice and just apple juice has a bunch of sugar in it.
So I went to like,
this is fucking hilarious.
It says health food store,
but like,
they don't like gays.
Funniest fucking thing.
I was like,
how did those things go together?
It's usually like,
hey man,
here's some vitamins.
And everybody's like,
everybody,
man.
Uh,
who the fuck would it?
Who Ever saw that coming?
Um,
um,
so yeah,
I would love to do that.
Like,
uh,
two as you saw some of the shit that I'm fucking eating,
they'll look at this fucking,
I Miss Boston.
Just saw a guy,
he had a red sox like knitted cap on with the Tom Brady Jersey in a glove
sitting right along the third base line.
Fucking hilarious.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I would love to do that.
Um,
I like vegetarian and Vegan meals,
but I also still like steak,
but I know if I combine like all of that shit,
I can still eat a little bit like John Wayne and not have a problem.
Um,
all right.
You disrespected miles Davis.
You can't.
All right.
What does this,
hey bill in season two,
episode four of F is for family.
There is an album cover parodying the miles Davis kind of blue.
In the background of one scene in the corner of the cover,
there appears to be a label of Bluenote records in this case,
black note records.
Uh,
these two instances of factual are factually incorrect.
Dude,
how much
you fucking jazz guys,
you know,
back in the fucking day,
I used to host this show called the jazz oasis on,
on uh,
the fuck was it?
88.9.
Okay.
W E r s at Emerson College.
And I used to find,
I didn't know fucking anything about jazz and I'd asked You fucking assholes to
call and request and none of you motherfuckers would call in.
All you would do is wait for me to play a record and then all you fucking cunts
would get on the phone and call me and be like,
fuck you.
Play in that four man in a jazz.
The fuck is it did a jazz motherfucker.
All you fucking guys can go fuck yourself.
Go sit on your fucking horn.
All right.
First of all,
did,
did you enjoy the show?
Did you enjoy the episode?
Listen to this ass.
Those are for actually incorrect kind of blue was released,
released on Columbia records.
Nobody likes labels,
record labels more than these fucking jazz people.
And Miles Davis at the time had not recorded for blue note.
Uh,
in a number of years.
You might want to get your facts straight.
You believe this shit.
If you want to reference the greatest jazz record of all time,
it may be who've you to respect,
respect,
possibly the greatest musician of the 20th century by simply getting some simple
factual information correct on your show.
You had dumb cunt.
Tony Williams is probably ashamed of you.
Let's be honest.
All right,
sir.
I'm going to walk you back through all your bullshit.
Okay?
First of all,
the reason why it didn't say Bluenote or Columbia records is because we would
have had that.
We would had to get permission to do that.
That's also the reason why the song kindness sounded like kind of blue,
but was it because we don't have the fucking budget to use that music.
All right.
That's why,
that's why it looked like that.
Okay.
And then secondly,
Tony Williams didn't play on that record.
You dumb.
Fuck
I then for the record,
I thought it was Philly,
Joe Jones.
I looked it up.
It was like some Guy Jimmy carb or something.
I hope I got his fucking name wrong.
Just so you can blow another gasket.
Fuck all you jazz guys.
You stupid cunt.
You're not,
you're not making an animated show.
You have no fucking idea how much money music costs.
That's why we did that.
Okay.
It w we weren't disrespecting miles Davis.
Okay,
so why don't you take all your words like behoove stick him in your clarinet and
shove it up your ass.
You pretentious fucking cunt.
Ah,
did that feel good?
He didn't even,
he didn't get the right drummer after giving me shit.
He didn't even get the right fucking drummer.
Tony Williams as part of the second grade quintet.
I do know that,
but I don't,
I don't know shit about jazz.
But I do know that the reason why we did that was because it would
Columbia records and Bluenote probably wouldn't have given us permission.
And if they did,
it would have cost us more money than it costs to fucking make the whole and we
would've been screwed.
That's why sir.
Okay.
So we didn't disrespect them.
We tipped our fucking cap tool.
Um,
by the way,
do you play any instrument?
Are you in a band?
All right.
Anger issue.
So this could not come at a better time.
Anger issues.
Uh,
we're gonna have anger issues if we don't get out of this fucking any.
All we did,
we finally got out of the inning.
Um,
dear Billy,
red top dear bill.
Bill red top.
Okay.
I had anger issues when I was younger.
Oh my God,
it's,
this is going to be a rail light.
I had a good family,
but I grew up in a neighborhood that exposed me to shit I shouldn't have seen.
Uh,
as a defense,
I started reacting to everything with anger and it carried on into my adult
life.
Uh,
did I write this in a drunken state and I forgot,
cause this sounds like me.
I've read lots of books and even wrote a few unpublished ones on the topic
myself.
So you actually worked on it.
I commend you for that.
I just like try for a few days and then I just go back to what I know anyways.
It kept me from being the happiest I could be.
It didn't ruin my life,
but it's kept me from enjoying things.
I had a bad habit of looking at people who are happy and finding reasons not to
like them.
I don't do that.
I think I did that my twenties,
but I,
I,
I'm not like that.
Uh,
even people I was close to,
which may sound strange.
Nope,
I did that a long time ago and then I've also had that done to me.
Um,
I remember when I bought my old truck,
68 f 100 short bed.
This guy was like,
what'd you get to truck?
Huh?
Hey,
you're going to put stuff back there.
Just like annoyed because everybody was looking at my truck.
Go do that thing is so fucking bad ass.
Nobody has that out here.
This thing's a shit,
you know.
Anyways,
I've been catching up on your podcasts over the last year and I've heard you go
from being much very angry to still pretty being pretty Angley but certainly
less angry than before.
I'm glad you've made strides.
Well,
not on this podcast because I can tell you the most important thing I gained
from reprogramming,
my immediate reaction to everything from anger to observance is time.
I'm not smart enough to only read that sentence once I got to do this again.
Uh,
I can tell you the most important thing I gained from recaro reprogramming,
my immediate reaction to everything from anger to observance is time.
What does that mean?
You got time back or something or you,
you're enjoying your life more.
You cause you don't have to spend so much of it apologizing for what you did an
hour ago anyways.
It's sneaky though.
Being angry can waste a whole day and you can do things while still being
agitated,
but you don't feel like you're completely unaccomplished.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't stay angry for a whole day.
Uh,
I just do like in spurts.
Okay.
And it goes all the way up to the top.
Then it come back down and worried.
Cause what's the Hell's wrong with you?
I've got your right.
Sorry.
You know,
I'm just trying to fucking take my work.
Uh,
you still ran your,
your errands and did your jobs and fed your kid,
et Cetera,
but you probably ignoring things you could be doing to advance yourself.
Uh,
you're likely not appreciating those.
Who are we talking about here?
Is this me?
My goodness.
A stern talking to um,
are you just a hypothetical you,
but you're probably ignoring things you could be doing to advance yourself.
You're likely not appreciating those around you who make your life good because
you are focused on people who make your life terrible or projecting things on
people that aren't there.
Um,
I don't do any of that with anybody in my life.
I do that with the people that are in power.
I do that a lot.
You know,
like I was all ready to fucking talk about everybody at best buy this is like
two podcasts in a row and they've done nothing wrong.
It's just been me needing to make a couple adjustments anyways.
My biggest regret in all my anger years was snapping at people who are genuinely
good people who didn't have that angry gene.
It's like being six foot one,
two 15 kicking the hell out of a small kid.
They can't defend themselves because if they do,
they become the maniac.
You are horrible,
horrible position to put someone in.
Hope you cross the finish line to zen?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I think I'm,
I'm somewhere in the middle of angry and Zen,
believe it or not,
as much as I flip out,
like I was,
I was a lot worse,
but,
uh,
I don't wish bad shit on people
and,
um,
I don't resent anybody.
Okay.
I don't,
I just,
it's,
you know what things,
things make me freak up.
Anything tech technology related makes me flip up.
But you know what's funny is if I get something old,
I have all the patients in the world,
you know,
like if my old truck won't start,
I actually,
you know,
I may not,
I'm not going to say I enjoy it,
but I,
I find the process of figuring out what's wrong with it,
enjoyable.
And then learning,
you know,
as the truck gets fixed,
what that was,
why that happened,
how to prevent it in the future.
Uh,
I know,
I tell you this,
you know what,
playing drums really helped me get back into playing drums and,
uh,
you know,
meet Nia.
Having a kid,
just shit that made me happy,
uh,
has kinda gotten me to that.
But my big thing is if I could just stop snapping,
that's kind of what I don't walk like,
you know what's funny is people actually think I am like an angry guy.
Like a walk around angry.
I don't,
I just snap.
MMM.
I'm definitely loud and I'm definitely fucking crazy.
But uh,
I dunno.
Maybe I'll let you guys be,
I don't classify myself as an angry guy.
Uh,
I saw,
I got to talking about my drinking.
Like I don't think I'm an alcoholic.
I don't think I'm an angry guy.
And I also think that I can admit when I'm wrong.
Fucking mess.
All right.
Dilemmas.
A dilemma.
Clarification number one,
Bill,
last week you read my dilemma wrong.
Oh,
sorry.
Geez.
Everybody coming at me.
Uh,
you have to either score perfectly on the sats with up to a year of studying or
in one sitting when a game of monopoly.
Oh,
in one city.
That means bankrupting all the other players.
Which one to save your life.
MMM.
Oh,
the fucking sats.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Those things are are pretty hard,
but fucking winning monopoly in one sitting.
I mean that's just,
I'd rather like sit down and like this time around really pay attention in math
class and and find out what I'm,
what this math is she is applied to as opposed to just being regurgitated at me.
Then sitting down and rolling dice like I'm in a fucking casino,
you know,
I mean Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine,
you know,
your life's on the line and you're moving a little dog or a shoe around a board.
I think I would much rather leave it up to my brain.
Okay.
Sort of a damned if you do,
damned if you don't come on get underneath that.
All right.
You ain't get a challenge as I'm okay.
Okay.
Yeah
Man on second top of the seventh one out.
Okay.
Dear Bill.
Dear dear bill to thought I have a dilemma for you,
would you rather have to fight an alligator in a water tank with a 12 inch blade
or fight an alligator in a room with a 30 inch aluminum baseball bat?
All right,
well we haven't talked about the size of the alligator.
I'm assuming it's big enough to kill me,
obviously.
Well,
I remember a long time ago,
I'm a cop told me if you're not going to get a gun to get a bat because you want
to have distance between you and the intruder.
So considering that the intruder is a fucking reptile pass ball,
he goes to third.
Fuck.
Um,
I would,
uh,
okay.
Yeah,
I take the the baseball bat.
Okay.
And the weird thing about an alligator is you got to come at them straight on.
Right?
Or from behind those fucking things.
You don't want to be on the side.
They,
they,
they bite from the side.
If you're right in front of them,
you're all good.
That's why all those,
those fucking morons that go up and they stick to their,
their,
their arm in the guy's mouth.
The Guy
No fucking way.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
What a fucking play that was
dude.
Lay down the BOT,
that owl to bay guy came in.
Who the fuck was that?
Zander Bogart.
Who through that fucking ball.
Who true that ball.
Oh,
it wasn't who he was swaying.
Actually.
Actually it wasn't a good throw.
He got him
throw was high.
He slid wide.
Oh No,
they're going to reverse that,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
Oh,
you mother fucker.
That's going to be that.
He's safe anyways.
Yeah,
I would,
I would 30 inch aluminum bat.
Wait.
Yeah.
Wait,
wait a minute.
That's not that big.
It's only three feet.
MMM.
Yeah.
All right.
This is us just so weird.
I would attack the top of his head from behind,
but I'd start with his feet.
Well,
you know,
that would actually fucking kill me to do that to a living thing like that.
I'd have to fucking slowly chop it down.
I had attacked the fuck thanks fee.
Although I did see that one way,
that fuck on Rogan showed that with that alligator bit,
the other ones leg and just did the death row,
rip the fucking things leg off and the other one wasn't going like,
ah.
It was just going like,
and that's it.
Just fucking down at barely bled.
So,
yeah,
I think,
I think he just got to a,
maybe what I really love to do is just sort of somehow getting on its back,
rub its belly.
Oh,
I know what I would do.
I take my shirt off and I cover its eyes.
I've seen those guys do that.
Okay.
And then I would take that fucking bat and I would just wham,
right down on it's fucking,
you know,
and I,
I,
you know,
that would be,
I wouldn't want to kill an alligator.
I am terrified of those things,
but I don't live in the same world.
It does.
But if it was me and him,
I mean that thing has to go.
MMM.
I've eaten alligator though.
Night alligator.
When I was in Florida.
It was fucking gross.
Just too Goddamn Gamey.
People like gay,
you know,
get tastes like chicken.
It doesn't,
it doesn't.
Chicken is fucking delicious.
Steers are delicious.
Those are the pigs are delicious.
Those are the three fucking best tasting things.
Turkey's a good,
they dry out though.
You know,
that's what I think.
Like you get to the upper level of,
you know,
if you have a smoker,
if you actually know how to smoke Turkey,
how the fuck did I do an hour and 20 minutes?
I'm all right.
That's the podcast.
I really appreciate people who are trying to help me with my temper because I
would like,
I mean,
I need to learn to like how to stop fucking snapping.
Um,
that's the big thing.
You know,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I do ramp it up a little bit when I'm on the podcast just to entertain you guys.
Put a,
that is,
that was pretty legit earlier in this show.
All right,
that's the podcast here.
I'll check in on you on,
um,
on Thursday.
Go fuck yourselves at a,
I have a wonderful couple of days.